HONOR IS SEAN TONIGHT THE
HATE TRUMP MEDIA MOB ARE
CONTINUING SMEAR CAMPAIGN
NOW THEY ARE TARGETING
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM AFTER
HE ENCOURAGED DONALD TRUMP
JR. TO EXERCISE FIFTH
AMENDMENT RIGHTS IN RESPONSE
TO A SENATE PANEL SUBPOENA
ABOUT HIS RUSSIAN CONTACTS.
FOR THE RECORD, DON JR.
SPENT NEARLY 30 HOURS
TESTIFYING ALL RIGHT.
WHEN IS ENOUGH ENOUGH?
TAKE A LOOK.
>> IT'S PROGRESS, YES.
HAVE YOU U.S. SENATORS
TELLING THE PRESIDENT'S
FAMILY TO IGNORE THE RULE OF
LAW.
>> HE IS CHAIR OF THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
>> YES.
I KNOW HIS NUMBERS WERE
HORRIBLE BEFORE HE STARTING
DONALD TRUMP'S BFF.
BUT IS IT WORTH IT?
THAT'S AN ANSWER, YOU KNOW,
ONLY HE CAN PROVIDE.
CHRIS, LINDSEY, IF YOU HAVE
AN ISSUE WITH ANYTHING I'M
SAYING, YOU KNOW MY NUMBER,
BABY.
GIVE ME A CALL.
>> Sean: CAN I JUST HELP
THESE PEOPLE OUT.
THE FIFTH AMENDMENT IS THE
RULE OF LAW.
A RULE OF LAW IS BASED ON A
LITTLE DOCUMENT CALLED THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES.
THE SENATOR IS STANDING
STRONG SUPPORTING THE
PRESIDENT'S AGENDA AND IT'S
CREATING RECORDS ON EVERY
FRONT.
EXPOSING THE DEEP STATE CAN
A BOWL BY PUSHING FOR MORE
FISA DECLASSIFICATION,
SECURING OUR BORDER JUST NEW
BILL TO REFORM THE ASYLUM
PROCESS.
HERE TO EXPLAIN MORE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN
LINDSEY GRAHAM HIMSELF.
MAYBE I IT'S BEEN A LONG
TIME SINCE I HAVE BEEN IN
SCHOOL BUT THE FIFTH
AMENDMENT, I THOUGHT, WAS
OUR RIGHT TO INVOKE.
DO WE NOT HAVE -- DOES THAT
RIGHT GET TAKEN AWAY AND I
MISSED IT.
>> LET ME TELL YOU WHY I
WEIGHED IN ON THIS.
MUELLER, I THOUGHT, WAS THE
FINAL WORD ON ALL THINGS
CRIMINAL.
THE LAST THING YOU WANT,
SEAN, IS 535 SPECIAL
COUNSELS.
RICHARD BURR IS A GOOD
FRIEND OF MINE.
HE IS A GREAT CHAIRMAN OF
THE INTEL COMMITTEE.
HE IS GOING TO ISSUE A GOOD
REPORT, I THINK, TELLING US
HOW TO DEAL WITH RUSSIA IN
THE FUTURE.
AND WHAT HAPPENED ON THE
INTEL SIDE.
WHAT I WORRY ABOUT IS WHEN
IS ENOUGH ENOUGH?
NOW, YOU HAVE GOT THE HOUSE
INTEL COMMITTEE BRINGING
ACCUSATIONS AGAINST JAY
SEKULOW AND.
>> Sean: IT'S RIDICULOUS.
>> JARED KUSHNER'S LAWYER.
THAT THEY CONSPIRED WITH
MICHAEL COHEN TO LIE TO THE
HOUSE INTEL COMMITTEE.
WHAT YOU SEE HAPPENING IS
CONGRESSIONAL COMMITTEES ARE
NOW BEGINNING TO TAKE THE
PLACE OF PROSECUTORS.
AND THAT'S DANGEROUS FOR US
ALL.
AND IF I WERE DON JR.'S
LAWYER, I WOULD BE RELUCTANT
TO PUT HIM BACK IN AN
ENVIRONMENT WHERE TWO OF THE
PEOPLE ON THE INTEL
COMMITTEE IN THE SENATE ARE
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT THE
UNITED STATES.
THEY WANT TO IMPEACH BARR.
THEY WANT HIM TO RESIGN.
THEY WANT ME TO RESIGN.
AND THEY THINK BRETT
KAVANAUGH WAS BILL COSBY IN
HIGH SCHOOL.
THESE PEOPLE ARE GOING NUTS.
>> Sean: THEY WANT A
DO-OVER.
LAST TIME I CHECKED, TOO.
NOT ONLY DID WE HAVE A FIFTH
AMENDMENT RIGHT.
WE HAD SOMETHING CALLED
ATTORNEY-CLIENT PRIVILEGE.
I THINK THAT EXISTS.
>> CAN WE PLAY THAT OUT A
BIT?
NADLER IS GOING TO GET TRUMP
REELECTED MORE THAN ANY
SINGLE PERSON ON THE PLANET.
>> Sean: MAYBE ADAM SCHIFF.
>> A CLOSE SECOND.
SCHIFF IS SAYING IS HE GOING
AFTER THE PRESIDENT'S LAWYER
ABBY LOWELL JARED KUSHNER'S
LAWYER BASED ON THE WORD OF
MICHAEL COHEN.
WHAT I WORRY ABOUT DON JR.
IF WE USE MICHAEL COHEN
TESTIMONY WE WILL BE GOING
AFTER EVERYBODY IN AMERICA.
RICHARD BURR IS A WONDERFUL
FELLOW.
MY PROBLEM IS NOT WITH
RICHARD BURR.
>> Sean: I HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH RICHARD BURR.
YOU AND I DIFFER HERE.
>> I DON'T.
>> Sean: HE SPENT 30 HOURS.
NOW SOMEBODY THAT AGAIN,
ADMITTED TO LYING BEFORE
CONGRESS, OKAY?
>> RIGHT.
>> THEN A CRIMINAL REFERRAL
WENT FORWARD BY JIM JORDAN
AND MARK MEADOWS ABOUT THE
SECOND APPEARANCE.
AND SO AT THIS POINT, ALL
RIGHT.
I WANT TO ASK YOU THIS:  SO
WE ARE GOING TO, IN THE DAYS
AHEAD.
WE ARE GOING TO GET THE FISA
APPLICATIONS.
GRASSLEY, GRAHAM MEMO.
BULK OF THE APPLICATION IS
HILLARY BOUGHT AND PAID,
UNVERIFIED DOSSIER WHICH
EVEN THE DOSSIER'S AUTHOR
DOESN'T STAND BY.
THEN WE WILL GET THE 302
MEETING NOTES WITH OHR AND
CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
THEN WE ARE GOING TO GET THE
GANG OF 8 MATERIAL WHICH I
UNDERSTAND IS NOT REALLY
GOOD ABOUT THE FBI ADMITTING
THINGS THEY DID WRONG.
THE FOURTH BRACKET WE TALK
ABOUT ARE A SERIES OF EMAILS
THAT HAVE SOME REALLY
SERIOUS ADMISSIONS IN THEM,
AMONGST THE FBI.
AND THE FIFTH BUCKET WILL BE
EXCULPATORY STATEMENTS THAT
THEY DIDN'T USE ON PURPOSE.
ANYTHING ELSE THAT WE'RE
GOING TO FIND OUT OUR DEEP
STATE DID TO TRY AND UNDO A
PRESIDENT ELECTION,
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION?
>> I THINK YOU ARE GOING TO
GET ALL OF THAT HOPEFULLY IT
WILL BE DECLASSIFIED AND
GIVEN TO THE PUBLIC.
I DON'T KNOW IF ANYBODY ON
THE OTHER SIDE WILL CARE,
WHICH WILL BE THE SAD THING.
YOU KNOW, ALL OF MY FRIENDS
AT CNN ARE GOING NUTS OVER,
YOU KNOW, MY CONCERN ABOUT
CONGRESS GETTING OUT OF ITS
LANE.
BUT HAVE YOU HEARD ONE
PERSON FROM THESE OTHER
NETWORKS EVEN SHOW CONCERN
THAT MAYBE THE FBI GAVE A
STATEMENT TO THE FISA COURT
THAT THE DOSSIER WAS
ACCURATE AND THEY TOLD OTHER
PEOPLE THAT THEY KNEW IT WAS
UNVERIFIED?
HAVE YOU HEARD ANY CONCERN
AT ALL ABOUT A
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
OPERATION THAT WAS BEING RUN
BY PEOPLE WHO HATED TRUMP
AND LIKED CLINTON?
>> Sean: SENATOR, WE NOW
HAVE TWO SOURCES THAT TOLD
THE FBI AND THE DOJ, THE
UPPER ECHELON, NOT RANK AND
FILE.
I ALWAYS MAKE THAT
DISTINCTION.
GOOD MEN THAT PROTECT US.
BUT, I AM TOLD IN BOTH CASES
THAT WITH THE DOSSIER, THAT
OHR WARNED THEM IT WAS
UNVERIFIED.
HILLARY PAID FOR IT.
STEELE HATED TRUMP.
NOW ALSO WE HAVE THE EMAILS
BEFORE THE FIRST APPLICATION
WENT IN.
IT SOUNDS LIKE A
PREMEDITATED CONSPIRACY TO
COMMIT FRAUD ON A FISA
COURT.
I'M ALSO HEARING HOROWITZ IS
DONE AND IT'S DEVASTATING.
ANY WORD THAT YOU ARE
HEARING?
>> I CAN'T VERIFY IF
HOROWITZ IS DONE.
I CAN'T TELL YOU WHAT HE
FOUND.
CAN I TELL YOU THAT IF YOU
CARE ABOUT THE RULE OF LAW,
YOU ARE GOING TO BE VERY
UPSET ABOUT HOW THE DOJ AND
THE FBI BEHAVED THEMSELVES
DURING THE 2016 ELECTION.
IF YOU HATE TRUMP, YOU WON'T
CARE.
IF YOU LOVE THE RULE OF LAW,
YOU WILL BE VERY UPSET.
>> Sean: SENATOR, I WILL
GLADLY ENDORSE YOUR
RE-ELECTION.
FOR SOUTH CAROLINA WHAT A
GREAT JOB YOU HAVE BEEN
DOING.
HAVE YOU BEEN LEADING ON ALL